hello welcome to this video playing the
Dark Passenger is actually an hour in
the bank oh and for a change and many
people play those some relatively big
lines against it or avoid it all
together so this is the modern mainline
we should be too as a move now 92 is
also possible Bishop d3 is a blunder do
tonight XD fight even though i recently
lost against this is always tricky nison
and blitz chess bishop d to our vests is
by far the main the main move
now you can take on your tool now or go
d6 like it I'll take
yeah the idea the idea is not be five
just wonder if it works e six is an
option here for black in those positions
this is a difference too many pure
bengkos it with the old move orders you
don't have six but here d 6 is not even
played so and that's kind of interesting
okay so i have d 5 now definitely all
night before let's go night before i
have to quit started took a rook f to be
eight hmm that was a serious option that
i did not look at I should have looked
at that
okay let's go to five it is also 9 27 26
cm
slightly awkward don't want to go back
to a 6 year but maybe I have to okay
yeah I definitely played something wrong
down entirely sure what exactly I did
wrong
maybe not playing would be ADA and don't
quite know I check the ICT with the
night does it help all that much ok I'm
going for c4 here so we a text you five
but I'm taking b3 salty probably has to
take
or that one or that one um hmm what to
do that was a good move
not quite sure I mean c3 that's f3 so
that that shouldn't work nights of five
also doesn't work okay so i can take
take and go a 585 of course you can also
take dd5 but this is some three against
two one one one side of the board okay
and then he wants to take your phone and
ok I might just lose on the spot here
now two points down you can just take 35
wow that looked like a really good game
by wide
at least I didn't quite spot what what
went wrong
time warning please I'm a little bit
actor here ok one may be odd it's not
necessary really
yeah it's just losing what can you do
yeah black resigns yeah I make mistakes
right right here because this position
is okay absolutely but I made mistakes
here probably a couple this is already I
don't like it with hindsight I can't do
this first and make him play a role to
be one this is better and then then go
from here and I can this that he has to
play this passive move first and then i
go here they're potentially d5 it really
should be okay i have 9 23 and so on
this is this is not really all that
great maybe I should go to d3 head up
like this the engine just believes i'm
finding and maybe because I already get
to spawn almost like here there's some
summer text going on and now here makes
you better so 93 is I just played this
rather quickly and not that quickly but
93 is a lot stronger and this was a good
move that was a really good move he's
threatening to take on you for and it's
it's very difficult to allow that may be
okay the engine wants me to do this but
couldn't quite believe it now it's
already a little bit of this position
now here can actually still equalize him
okay with this idea that that's totally
okay funny funny idea
this is okay three I saw this that that
I had to look at this move but you can
take with the night rope take this
Bishop age 60 it's one totally
impossible to see because I had some
idea with this but ok I went for this
and this is again a very strong covering
be three and yeah ultimately I went to
this but I knew that this is not not
going to be okay 96 probably have to go
look at the ATM but its spin now it's
just lost it's nothing nothing really
that you can try to pawn see as a stable
bishop the important is too much yeah I
made a couple of mistakes on the later
stages of the opening that give gave why
too much advantage okay well thanks for
watching